a lot of women
think that a liar is worse than a
cheater
you see what i'm saying with that but
they're are they how are they not
mutually well if alex and his let's use
alex as an example let's say you don't
have this
rad ass one-way relationship thing going
on
and he cheated
that'd be one thing
and if he said hey listen babe i [ __ ]
up last night all right i was an idiot i
was drunk i was at a strip club
[Music]
and explained it
it would be very difficult pill to
swallow but somewhat palatable however
if he did something wrong
and lied about it and she found out
that is a way worse situation for a
woman would you agree absolutely tell me
why because i'd be mad as hell mm-hmm i
just i like lying is the worst thing you
can do in a relationship like you know
what i mean like this is this is why i'm
saying i kind of like legit respect what
you're doing yeah
and i feel like a lot of people are
actually doing that more and more and
more because you know why guys cheat
so you might as well be like babe i
might stick my dick somewhere once in a
while but you're my girl
and you're okay with that i would be
okay with it as long as we communicated
that from the start so that's a mature
relationship these days i feel like it
is for a lot of people natalia you're
looking like you want to weigh in here
go you got some strong feelings here um
i don't know i just feel like it it has
to be obviously a mutual agreement
between the two but i also feel like
today
women are
i'm finding
women who are younger they are more
stern and like not allowing that like no
my man can't cheat i feel like when you
get older
into relationships you start to allow
things that you normally wouldn't when
you're younger
just because you're looking to like
settle down like time's ticking
so like i feel like if you ask younger
girls today they're like nah my man is
not gonna cheat but i think if you're in
a point where you're like you know i
want a man and i want to settle down
like
would i pick a man who in my eyes is
valuable and maybe that is the flaw of
the relationship but i'm still with
somebody i want to be with and i think
when you're younger it's more like
you're looking like they have to check
all your boxes you're more stern of
locking that in when you're younger and
i think you have a higher probability of
doing that because you're
you know you're
more valued i guess you could say in
men's eyes some men's eyes when you know
you're younger you're pretty and stuff
like that more men are willing to stop
certain habits to be with a girl than
when
they're so cheap
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]